We all wanna be looking and feline good, right?
I know, I can't help it, cat puns.
I bet our writer Chelsea White wrote that,
she's a real cat lady.
It's not easy being so purrfect.
Yep, that was another one.
Okay, why am I making, oh, so many cat puns?
And well, this is what happens when you improvise.
Okay, listen, it's time to dive into the history
of the cat eye and runways around the world
saw cat eyes strutting down the catwalk
to accompany the hottest looks of 2020 and 2021.
Now, let's let the cat out of the bag here right now
with this second in our series, I love these,
beauty backgrounder.
(upbeat music)
Let's claw back in time and discover
the history of the cat eye.
The cat eye was first seen in ancient Egypt
and the Middle East where kohl-cloaked eyes
were believed to provide a health boost
and minimize glare from the sun.
A decorated eye was also said to protect you
from the evil eye,
a curse transmitted through a malicious and envious glare.
Cat eyes prowl throughout history on high society women,
in ancient Rome and the 18th century Western Japan,
but the look really started to explode
when Western countries in the 1910s and '20s
first began to pillage artifacts from ancient Egypt
and Tut-mania inspired looks from older eras.
In the '20s, cosmetics became more acceptable for use
by mainstream women,
and flappers began to throw away rigid prim looks
for something a little bit more stylish.
In the '50s, people went paw-sitively wild for a cat eye
when liquid liner was invented
and the starlets of the silver screen
started rocking the look.
The '70s, '80s and '90s saw the feline look adapted
for punks, goths, grunge, male stars, such as David Bowie,
proof that a fierce look could be worn by any gender.
Today, the cat eye is still a fur-ocious statement.
And an Instagram search of the term
will give you endless references.
We love the cat eye because of its versatility.
From a subtle and classic application
to a subculture grunge look,
you can live a whole nine lives
with different takes on this feline-tastic makeup trend.
(upbeat music)